like Gianna when the nominations came
out you know I she told me she said see
that hard work makes the dream work
that's the best of course you have an
affair when you come out to benefit the
kids go in a positive way I love your
tall and weird little guys in aviator
are you a romantic kind of guy I guess
so I guess I know what I wanted to be I
guess I think every guy has a little no
romance inside of him most embarrassing
moment I was playing the all-star game
when I was in high school you know you
like you'd be real cool so you were like
real baggy shorts no I had a fast break
I was running I'm at the jump my choice
is fed out of my ankles but I had on
spandex so I was cool
I didn't show I didn't give him all my
stuff interested in meeting anybody
somebody get a chance to go out that way
so these are people that watch on TV you
know seeing movies and I respect in my
mind I'm so much so it's just uh just
walking around starstruck I'm like one
of the fans well Jennifer Lopez is uh
she's a bit
I'll be interesting me everybody's
wearing two-piece suits you got a
three-piece on Starling trying to keep
up with my wife we're doing a little
story just one like how people met how'd
you guys meet
ha ha we met actually a video shoot that
I was filming she was there and we
actually had when we first met we have
it on tape so we get to show our kids
you know that's when we first met we
caught it on tape so really we like kids
to know that all dreams are possible if
you believe in yourself
and this kind of reassures that speaking
of kids I hear you and your wife have
some great news these days yes you have
a beautiful baby girl
her name was Natalia diamante Bryant and
you know she's just she's amazing I was
there taking pictures helping you know
doing everything I possibly can to make
the process easier for my wife and you
know but ultimately you know she did all
the work I was just there just trying to
help I don't know I don't know maybe
tennis it all boils down to basketball
you know you can get caught up in all
the hoopla on a high but now ultimately
is you know playing the game it's
putting a round ball in the basket and I
just try to keep it as simple as that
just try to execute and it is still on
my team makes a work ethic of a champion
and see if we can't get it done one of
the amazing things that watches you
maintain your focus on basketball how do
you do that with the swirl of activity
around you know it's uh it's just guy
giving this guy giving just through
prayer he always gives you the strength
when you need it the most I can't take
credit for that you know just enjoy it
you know it's uh that's a lot of fun
because you know people that come to
watch us play via Denzel Washington or
Andy Garcia or Jack you know we're big
fans of them up there big fancy we go
watch them perform you know on the big
screen and now they come and watch us
perform and watch us do what we do best
and you know I take pride in that I'm
sure like teammates or is it hard
dealing with all the cameras constantly
flicking people yelling your name
it's fine everyone's sweet you know
they're professionals as long as they're
professionals
it's great yeah you have a couple idiots
out there basically huh some people are
real professional really nice but you
know you have a couple couple of nut
cases she's excited about today in the
game I mean it never gets old all-star
game no I never gets old it's always fun
it's always fun to be around so many
great players in this type of atmosphere
the first memory I have of Jerry Buss I
just had about a million things go
through my mind right now I think when I
first met him after you drafted me and
him telling me that he has confidence in
me that I'll be able to to live up to
the expectations I think that was that's
my most memorable experience that was
the first time with me meeting the owner
and you know it was a gutsy move because
they traded away a center of lot of
devices with proven center to draft some
seventeen year old kid and you know it
just gave me a lot of confidence yeah so
bro you got a bro well it's a blessing
yeah yeah God giving disabilities
a sense of purpose
so like this morning too so it's quite
fast
[Music]
are you a big fan of Jack Sparrow in
this franchise huge we all are yeah no
she's been counting down for this day we
all have for a good two months now so
pirate good you guys decided to go with
black no everyone else wearing pirate
gear well yeah well we have we have them
Skull and Bones skull and bones
no that was all wrong what's wrong with
you people respond to you and you come
out to these big things I feels like I'm
a stable sinner you know feel like I'm
back at home how much fun was it man you
know what I had so much fun it was a
blast it was absolute black different
events and you know just being around
athletes in the village I'm is just
unbelievable feeling what does this gold
medal mean to you because I saw the
celebration the joy on your face no this
is this is more special than the NBA
championship you know just because you
represent in your country and it's just
no greater honor launch the day of your
final shoe but also you've been going to
Hollywood after this you may become a
storyteller so there's more to you than
just basketball in your shoe yeah you
know it's all it's all kind of the same
thing you know storytelling through
product storytelling through your moving
pictures and things that nature you know
and the important thing is always trying
to trying to inspire and then trying to
teach kids in a very creative way would
you say that I enjoy doing zone and then
you probably spend more time with the
girls now absolutely yeah absolutely
that's the beautiful part about it I can
actually take the kids to work every
single day I think
our responsibilities always inspire and
try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned and share those
with the next generations so that they
can start their journey with a leg up
right they can start with the
information and the life lessons good or
bad that we have learned in our time and
this way they don't make the same
mistakes so it's extremely important to
teach these life lessons to these young
kids at every age we're doing in a
entertaining way because you know kids
will tune you out right if you'd like
you're preaching all the time there's
you be like yeah whatever right but if
you make it entertaining we make it
creative and all of a sudden these are
lessons that they are learning on their
own through the content versus us
parents you know constantly telling them
over and over and over they're starting
to sink in it's just how crazy this even
seeing you with a lot of different
trophies but what would it mean to hold
this Oscar up and be the first NBA
player to win enough you know I got to
say it's even more special to me than
winning the championship because you
guys a kid I dreamed of winning
championships yeah
when you dream of doing something new
accomplishing like I've seen that happen
since the age of two never in my wildest
dreams and I thought we've ever been
here the Oscar be nominated for an Oscar
that's insane now today you are number
one on New York bestseller list on New
York Times bestseller list what does
that feel like to be number one with the
book and a project that you love so much
it's a crazy feeling I mean you know to
have a crazy night crazy idea find a
great team to believe in the idea find a
great writer
Wesley King and take the idea and make
it a thousand times better than what it
was to be number one in New York Times
it's a great feeling
Gigi's a basketball player she is that
she's in it does she have that inner
focus like her daddy yeah she's she's
just don't call killer out there yeah at
both ends of the floor and she plays
defense as well as offense man she
competes you know when I tried to teach
the girls not just her but all the girls
on the team is it's a process she's just
working every day and we only started
playing about a year ago right so he's
just chipping away at things you just
get better and better we're just really
blessed very fortunate we have you know
three beautiful healthy young ladies and
with another one on the way so we're
just just very very fortunate
[Music]
you